[Music]
beautiful shot welcome back to cbs
mornings as the lane maxwell's sex abuse
trial enters its fifth day we're taking
a closer look at the psychology behind
human trafficking maxwell's accused of
finding teenage girls for jeffrey
epstein's alleged sex abuse ring some of
the alleged victims say epstein paid
them to recut up the recruit other girls
mulalengi looks at the complicated line
between being a victim and being an
accomplice he joins us from the federal
courthouse in manhattan where the trial
is taking place mola good morning
well good morning nate haley robson
tells us that she spent two years in
jeffrey epstein's alleged sex
trafficking ring that she was recruited
by a peer and then ultimately ended up
recruiting some of her own friends a
guilt she says she still carries with
her today
i wanted a fresh start haley robson says
she first met jeffrey epstein in 2002.
she was an unsuspecting 16-year-old high
schooler in west palm beach florida when
a classmate recruited her i was told the
more you do the more you make i was told
you know it would be possibly in your
bra and underwear but it would just be a
massage
desperate to leave behind childhood
trauma robson agreed to go to epstein's
palm beach estate she says the massage
turned into something more when epstein
masturbated and fondled her when he
tried to take it further she says she
refused that's when he offered to pay
her 200 dollars for every girl she
brought to him did you realize the
damage that he was doing to you i did
not understand
that i was being sexually abused i
didn't understand how to really classify
that
is it sexual assault is it rape is it
molestation i'm 16. robson recalls
seeing a girl come out of the bathroom
with epstein both in towels she was just
very closed off like holding herself
like this and walking out of the room
with her head down
and i know that look
it was
probably one of the only images
besides the actual abuse that i have
flashbacks
just the way that she was looking or not
looking never forget it
andrea powell was founder of karana
rising a support group for victims of
sexual abuse and exploitation it's very
difficult to get out and you may not
realize how deep you're in she says most
sex trafficking victims are subjected to
a complicated cocktail of reward and
abuse if you break it down traffickers
have three strategies and one is i can
be your daddy i can be your protector
the other is i can be your lover i can
be your boyfriend your partner and the
other is i can make your life better i
can fulfill your dreams and epstein was
able to kind of combine all of that at
its bones it's like every other case
exactly i mean take away the shiny toys
take away the money take away the fancy
names human trafficking sex trafficking
at its core is about someone exploiting
someone else's vulnerabilities hurt
people hurt people robson says she went
on to recruit eight other girls some
people look at me they don't know where
to place me were you a recruiter were
you a victim were you told what type of
girls to try to recruit specifically the
younger the better
i
brought the people that i hung out with
did you think you were helping them
yeah when i was 16 i felt like
hey you know i made money like do you
guys want to make money therapist randy
cogan has been working with robson for
the last two years
with haley i think the focus was more in
recruitment than abuse
so there was a lot of work to be done
with haley on
forgiving herself
for
making decisions that she did not have
any choice in making
while robson says she never met glenn
maxwell and is not part of the
government's case against maxwell she
has been compared to her she used her
gender to ultimately build trust with
underage girls
and it's not like she's 16 and doesn't
know any better she's an adult where is
the line between recruiting
while still being victimized and an
actual criminal accomplice the line is
can you walk away
can you get out and and i don't just
mean physically i mean psychologically
robson remembers when it all hit her i
was sitting in the
shower just
scrubbing my skin
scrubbing it
because i just felt so dirty
but some stains don't wash away
how has this affected your ability to
trust people i don't trust people
said you're a mother now
yeah
that's tough
i don't want her to feel or to go
through the things that i've gone
through a mother trying to protect her
daughter
better than she protected her friends
the guilt will never go away there is
not a day that goes by that i don't
think about the other girls
well maxwell has denied knowing anything
about jeffrey epstein's alleged sex
trafficking operation and she has
pleaded not guilty to the criminal
charges against her nate
mola thank you the daily mail is
reporting that glenn maxwell visited the
white house with jeffrey epstein in
1993. the daily mail says epstein
visited the white house at least 17
times from 1993 to 1995 while bill
clinton was president a spokesperson for
mr clinton declined to comment on the
report the daily mail says the story is
based on white house logs obtained
through the freedom of information act
request in the past former president
clinton has maintained there is no
connection between him and epstein's
alleged sex trafficking ring